[Music]
pewdiepie
face reveal face is revealed hello
everyone this is how it looks like
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old and i'll measure your peeps in the
next episode
guys you will not believe what i have
gotten
wait wait wait wait it goes like this
this is cool
you could have picked any instrument in
the world and i would have bought it and
you picked
the frog
rest in peace sleepy
this is you know he was he was about
this size actually
oh
i used to sit in that window
i miss him
i love that toad whatever [ __ ] it was i
don't know
i'm joking anyway cocomelon diss track
by the way coming out
this weekend prepare yourself
nothing personal kid
but i must go all out
just once
[Music]
good purchase very nice thank you for
the suggestion anyway let's see what you
guys have posted it gets really fast in
the end doesn't it did you just [ __ ]
say me to leave it you know i'm going to
give you open everything i'll let you
down
[Music]
how do i have this power
i know it doesn't work always
god damn it down vote
down vote i hate boomers i hate v tubers
i hate twitch thought
i don't hate twitch thoughts come on
i look better as a woman this isn't fair
this is [ __ ] this may not help kids
but it's interesting okay
why are wha what are these [ __ ]
tick-tock builds
oh my god that's genius
i want that different star wars
don't i have to name tag them so they
don't despawn or they will they not do
spawn that's that's pretty cool actually
that's awesome [ __ ] minecraft never
subs second february 2056 subscribe now
coco melon just it's coming this weekend
this weekend guys another teaser perhaps
there it is all right coming next
weekend guys it will be epic to say the
least petitioned to make this
pewdiepie's profile picture if he
decides to piss something
i can't help it should i change to the
female filter for this one
for no reason do not demonetize
for no reason dogs in minecraft when
someone hits their owner can't be
like true
me creating new accounts for the one
month free trial
how do you do the fat filter it's not a
filter felix okay shut up shut up shut
up bats locate their food using sound
[ __ ] lasagna oh sh
great meme fantastic i can't believe
this on it was like [ __ ] three years
ago wasn't it god damn it
more music coming guys big booba big
titty oh my god i'm an idiot
oh my god
how did i not think of that big tittie
right there kid should add his heartbeat
when he's playing minecraft i mean some
parts i'm not gonna lie when i did the
woodland mansion it's coming up very
soon i was [ __ ] myself dude i've
never been so nervous playing a video
game me a male finally gets into hawaii
but gets big booba instead of big peepee
guess i'm woman
dear pewdiepie please piss off the smr
community next thank you what's wrong
with the asmr community why would we do
this to them i wouldn't purposely just
try and piss someone off that would be
childish immature and irresponsible hey
[Music]
hey guys
it's me
that's hella gay felix thank you thank
you thank you since felix is a woman now
i challenge him to buy this yeah i
thought it was uh it seemed like a good
idea for no reason at all to not push
the envelope on that joke so i decided
to stop it
before
i just have this thing in my track
record i just tend to things tend to be
funny for a long time and then it just
i tend to in my experience it's better
to just end the joke before you get
canceled you live and you learn gamers i
have the most team i am the most saying
what's that poke amateurs
god damn it i could have milked it
should couldn't i i could have gotten
that e girl money
[ __ ] [ __ ] i [ __ ] up getting in my
2020. i see your schwartz just as big as
mine getting in the way 2021
big bubba
all right you know what i missed the
filter this is ugly i don't know no one
wants to see this hold up
what the hell is hey
i'm a bad bad guy i gotta go gamers
unsubscribe from coca-melon my fellow
nine-year-olds unsubscribe now and
subscribe to pewdiepie
immediately or else
we baby now what else do we got here oh
what the [ __ ] is this now all right this
works i can still i can get
yeah
oh
[Music]
i don't know man
oh found it i'm back [ __ ] i'm back to
[ __ ] you up god damn i look like a mean
[ __ ] dude all right for lawyer we're
keeping this
come to poppy
okay
what the [ __ ] does this mean for man
come come
as a woman
oh
i don't like it
i don't like it thank you i figured this
out but yes i saw someone uh die from
this
because they're like ah look guys i have
fire rest potion jump in lava
pits in minecraft look at that little sh
i'm gonna make you work until you die
much
oh you think she's confused why
shouldn't he if you're a woman your
minecraft skin should be woman too holy
[ __ ] that is so beautiful what a
beautiful lady who's more likely to have
a sex change
damn it
what
the [ __ ] is this
endorsing him is an endorsement of white
supremacy endorsing you want to endorse
in me me a black guy reading this maybe
i am a white supremacist
so [ __ ] dumb dude people think this
too i know how everyone clown on that
dumbass i realized what it is you know
on like a video there's always no matter
what there's a tiny portion of dislikes
no matter how good of a video it could
be like i'm donating
to save the universe
there will still be dislikes on that
video but for some reason
uh with twitter or whatever you can
always find like that tiny person with a
dumbass opinion and for some reason you
know even though you have all these
people that
don't think something and you have this
tiny portion thinking the other way for
some reason this portion gets just as
much its attention if not more than all
these people that don't give a sh so
what we need to do
is just
how do i joke about this without getting
canceled um
kill them sorry that was a joke okay uh
i'm joking i i am a woman now guess i'm
a lesbian
always has been you are a sewage water
water cat jargon who is drinking it for
weeks
no
bad euro again that's what makes him
strong that's what makes him so stallion
and beautiful lord forgive me for what
i'm about to what the [ __ ] say
stop it stop it
you like to dress up i said stop all
right i'm ending this meme i'm ending
this [ __ ] meme this is [ __ ] i'm
vaping now all right baby now i didn't
like dressing up as a girl my mom liked
dressing me as a girl it's very
different understand i am man i'm a big
tall man very strong
okay understand
pewdiepie pewdiepie it's your fault
watercat it is that's good are you
pissing me off now hit the subscribe
button right here and i'll make face
reveal yeah guys
subscribe and unsubscribe from kokomo
and do it right now it's a joke by the
way just so we're clear i'm not serious
it's just for good fun coco melon do not
sue me
okay thank you uh i have nothing new to
wear boys
i respect that
yeah he kept that for a long ass [ __ ]
time hey if you find a shirt that fits
you well why the [ __ ] not uh it turns
female every 19 year old he was supposed
to destroy the sims what does this make
me now huh i hate babies they're dumb
they're so stupid
i'm faster i'm stronger i'm smarter
i could beat the [ __ ] out of them yeah a
lot of things i could do a lot of things
hey it's me and i've been a fan for
years no
i'm sorry i'm sorry vlad slick bartender
i'm sorry i judged you wrong
it was just that other cake lady thank
you vlad that's so that's really cool i
i feel like a dick now god damn it
that's big tt people disagree with putin
putin wow
just disappeared that's so crazy i can't
believe it my gender transformation from
big b peepee to big boop
after swedish woman on youtube live set
by me
oh what the [ __ ]
is this part of the diss track uh yes
absolutely i build pewdiepie's logo in
minecraft oh sick so you actually did it
no way
how how how that's sick they uh
the [ __ ] does kids like i guess big titi
they like big titties still it still
applies big titi oh my god
yeah i know how to make caldron it's
upside down pants
oh yeah
my minecraft new minecraft new that is
so cute
someone just posted their [ __ ] dog
i think i've been playing too much
minecraft there's not enough space for
memes now i'm sorry
it's just so much fun i love playing
minecraft i can't help it oh they fixed
it hell yeah i like it i'm saving that
[ __ ]
god damn it
looks like [ __ ] brad dude i was
explaining to my mom what is a rickroll
and she gave me this oh [ __ ] it
old-school rickroll right there
[ __ ] just handing someone a [ __ ] lp
nothing like g field to get me through
hard long work days thank you pewds for
bringing us my laughter and fuel to
fight fires you're awesome you're
awesome what the [ __ ]
i hope you don't use that to put on fire
oh man i guess he does in a way because
it fuels him
that's all that's so awesome all right
so i have i finally connected with laser
lava for those who don't know the
legendary g-fuel cup guy and i wanted to
talk to him to ask him some questions
because i'm i've always been very uh
impressed with his life accomplishments
let me remove this dumbass filter for
this hell yeah well well well well
don't
one year later
here we go here we go oh yeah it took a
while it took a while sorry about that
um
it's all right man okay good
slive did it to me so i was used to it i
did it to you i can't believe it dude he
said he's like yo let's record like last
year when i did the video with him he's
like let's record and so i like sat in
the discord call and then like a week
later he messages and he's like sorry i
was busy can we do it tomorrow
and i'm like
simon's no excuse to be busy no no no
excuse i'm like
you can edit videos and you can talk to
me that's it yeah that's it that's funny
that well i'm glad we finally connect
man
finally
so uh i i just wanted to call because i
i have a lot of questions and i'm very
curious okay yes
go ahead because i i didn't watch the
side video so maybe you went through
this already with him mm-hmm i kind of
did yeah okay well the g fuel isn't real
how many how many g fuels do you have
right now
so i don't have
any shakers other than the ones i have
for my personal collection anymore which
is like i have the the black friday one
the blue one the okay the clear one i
have
the shakers
and i had i actually had 69
shakers and i bought them and i had them
in my room the picture with like me
buried in all of them yeah i think
blender
that does look like it yeah yeah
somebody made that did g fuel send you
any at all yeah so uh you can see in my
camera here there's a shelf wait i can't
see it i can't see it i know you can't
see it oh okay but in the video you'll
see it but there's legit 40 cans of that
um i uploaded that picture like a while
back of me with all of them on the desk
they legit reached out to me and we're
like hey we love how passionate you are
about like pewdiepie's merch line i'm
glad yeah that's cool gift and i'm like
heck yeah
let's do that and i made a video on it
and it was so cool and it's a it's so
good dude it's my favorite g flavor
honestly thanks man yeah i think so too
i legit think so too
where did the idea come from you just
like i want to buy a bunch of [ __ ]
like i don't understand that but it's
very impressive
yeah it's the story came from
if you remember people were putting
uploading pictures onto the subreddit of
them in like their 100 mil merch and
they're like oh look at me i'm a woman
i'm wearing the 100 merch and they get a
bunch of upvotes and i'm like you just
wanted to put women in their place i see
how it is
i thought okay i have like 15 hoodies of
his because i like i love i like the
merch oh yeah and i wear it thank you
i was like okay how about i put all of
it on at the same time and i just flex
on everyone who's showing off their one
piece of merch hell yeah and i had my
two shakers up there the tall one and
the short one yeah and then you said it
all started because you said
like that yes more than i have that's
that is true absolutely now yeah
instantly i was like
i gotta get more now so i got four
and then you reacted again i did not
remember and it's all coming back
i did this kept on buying them
and then a lot of people were saying
like oh my goodness he's going to get 69
of them and then i was like well now i
have to then you have so i got 69 of
them and if you remember
i uploaded a picture with the 69 of them
and i was like if you let me host meme
review i'll give these all away oh my
god i probably shouldn't have said that
it feels like i was asking that hey let
me host meme review so i gave them away
anyway so that's cool olivier
i legit forgot about that but hey no
that's all right you can host the y here
you go
heck yeah here we go
i've already done it sorry you can't but
no heck
dang it
it's so cool i really appreciate it i
think it's a good meme it was it was
just fun it's like a great meme i
actually saw
on like instagram people were making
memes of me and they weren't even like
i still see your picture show up from
time to time it's funny yeah yeah yeah
they're like nobody the dude in the math
problem and i have like all these
shakers i saw that yeah that's funny
also
congratulations
thank you recently engaged well done
thank you so much
um you are invited to the wedding thank
you
that might be difficult now when is it
happening october oh really it's gonna i
i want it to happen when hopefully
the thing that happened last year goes
away right um thank you for saying that
we
later in the year also my fiance wants a
fall wedding and i think fall weddings
are really cool too good good car yeah
we were actually supposed to look at the
venue today but it is snowing like crazy
it's snowing hair and tears no serious
first time of the year sewing here yeah
that's crazy wow congratulations you
congratulations to you
yeah but i'm glad i didn't because i
wouldn't be talking to you right now i'd
be looking at a venue so thank goodness
for snow
well don't tell your fiance but okay
no she didn't want to drive in the snow
anyway okay fahrenheit
so
you proposed for those who don't know on
the subreddit what made you think of
that
well so
we've been together for a while not as
long as not as long as like you would
marzia yeah like i knew that like from
the first you know few months we were
together i was like you know this is
i don't i don't want anybody else this
is what i want you know you know we're
gonna
yeah and we talked about it and so it's
like a mutual thing we knew that like we
wanted to get married and i thought like
how am i gonna propose you know am i
going to do the classic like oh take her
out to dinner and then get down on one
knee i'm like no
that's cliche that's kind of like [ __ ]
i do have a following on the subreddit
that's what i did
i took care of it what are you saying
cliche
this is [ __ ]
i never actually knew how you did that
you just yeah we saw like the twitter
we had like a 12 course dinner or
something more wow yeah so i i assumed
she watched the y as well or yeah so she
knew about my whole shaker ordeal and
she said it's funny and you know she's
always been supportive of that and so
i uploaded the picture to the subreddit
and instantly took off it just blew up
because i i kind of figured it would
because something like that
means standing in the bathroom with
sweatpants oh that's right
i'm sorry
i did dog
[Laughter]
okay well i thought it was really
wholesome i thought it was really nice
yeah
that's all i needed you know people oh
man i have gotten so much like
controversy over the post that i made
because most some people were like yo
don't do that you need to do something
more romantic whatever it's like no
yeah i respect that you know what you
want yeah and i know exactly what she
would want too and she thought it was
great and like
you know she didn't she wasn't expecting
like a oh take her out to dinner you
know or whatever like make a huge reveal
this is just the thing of the internet
where everyone wants to have their
opinion about everything so welcome to
that
i just watched your your vtuber
controversy there you go it came through
[ __ ] man
that's how it is
yeah that's cool man well congrats again
that's amazing thank you so much what's
so great to be congratulated
do you have any other memes in mind or
any
anything else
i think i've met my peak you know i
got 69 shakers i became a meme
i'm talking to the number one most
subscribed youtube channel oh yeah and
my favorite youtube channel i've been
watching you since you made like outlast
videos oh [ __ ] thanks man yeah it's just
great and i think this is where this is
where it ends and i i did do like a you
like youtube videos don't say that you
made a thing yeah i was i was just gonna
ask this sir
is there anywhere where people can check
you out if there's anything i feel like
you at least deserve a shout out for all
the me the meme currency
you already shouted me out
really cool well i'll tell people that
lizard lava 808 is the youtube channel
it's basically it's my name on
everything so
you know if you ever want to look for me
just look for a lizard lava 808 listen
lava 808 cool man well great talking to
you and dude again congrats so much keep
meming please do it though it'll be fun
to see you pop up every once in a while
i know you're saying
make it 69 gamer chairs
okay we'll see hey let me know if you
have any ideas it could be fun to see
but yeah yeah yeah all the best thanks
again man dude thank you so much
all right take care man
yeah you do but all right cool
um
yeah a bit different for our lawyer but
i thought it could be funny to chat with
some of the memers who supported the the
show because you guys are literally the
ones making lil way after all i'm just
sitting on my [ __ ] desk here
so it's all i thought it would be
interesting to chat with uh some of the
people behind here if there anyone that
comes to mind uh like lizard lava let me
know it'd be cool to hit people up make
this more of a community thing and uh
yeah that's it for this week's lawye
thank you for subscribing coco melon
juice track very soon and i see you guys
next time bro fist